they can't they can but the least happy  demographic of women is women over the  ages of 45 that make between I think  it's like  between 50 to like seventy thousand  dollars per year and are single and  childless like life  what are they bothered about people yeah  they're the least happy demographic like  life gets pretty lonely after the age of  45 like right you know I don't think as  women we really understand how different  the world treats us because we're pretty  women  and and because one day your looks are  going to be gone you're gonna get no  attention from men like 40 40 but no no  men are lining up to date 50 year olds  it's a good thing I got personality then  isn't it that won't work that won't work  we don't care